[موسيقى]
البرتغالي نونو سانتو يثير الجدل حول
مستقبله مع الاتحاد بعد تتويج بالدور
السعودي
بهتافات مدويه جمهور النصر يغسل احزان
كريستيانو رونالدو
يعتذر من مشجعه في المدرجات
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم عبر قناه
العربيه رياضه وسعدوا بمتابعتكم
نبدا اخبارنا لهذا اليوم من السعوديه حيث
اثار البرتغالي نونو سانتو الجدل خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه عبر السوشيال
ميديا بعدما رفض المدرب حسم مستقبله مع
ناديه الاتحاد المتوج تحت قيادته بلقب
الدوري السعودي للمحترفين لاول مره منذ
2009 مدرب توتنه وولفرهامبتون وبورتو
السابق اطفال غموض والجدل بشان مستقبله
وسط شائعات تحوم حول رحيله واكتفى بالقول
اعيش يوما بيوم اليوم احتفال وغدا عطله ثم
سنستعد للمباراه القادمه بنفس الالتزام
والانضباط وهذا ما اركز عليه فقط
ونبقى مع الدوري السعودي حيث انتشر فيديو
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لجمهور النصر
وهو يهدف باسم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو بصوت عال رغم خساره الدوري كنوع
من التقدير والتحيه له على ادائه مع
الفريق وانتقاله لصفوفه في سوق الانتقالات
الشتويه الماضيه ونجح رونالدو في تسجيل 14
هدفا في تسعه عشره مباراه لعبها مع النصر
في كافه البطولات هذا الموسم ويعد هذا
الموسم هو الثاني على التوالي الذي يليه
الدون دون التتويج باي لقب مع الفرق التي
لعبها لها بعد الموسم الماضي حين كان
يدافع فيه عن الوان مانشستر يونايتد
ننتقل الى فرنسا حيث شهدت مباراه باريس
سان جيرمان في الدوري المحلي لقطه طريفه
بطلوها كيليان مبابي فخلال التدريبات
تدريبات الاحماء قام لاعب باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي بتسديد كره قويه ضلت
طريقها الى المدرجات واصطدمت بوجه مشجعه
للفريق هذا الحادث دفع مبابي لاخذ الفتاه
المشجعه لدكه البدلاء والطلب من الفريق
الطبي الاطمئناني على اصابتها واسعافها
الامر لم يتوقف هنا فبعد انتهاء المباراه
وتتويج سان جيرمان بالدوري الفرنسي ذهب
اللاعب للاطمئنان على الفتاه والاعتذار
لها مره اخرى ومن هي ايضا تيشيرت الخاص به
كهديه وسط تصفيق الجماهير
الختام معلوتون تاون صاحب اغرب ملعب في
تاريخ الدوري الانجليزي هذا النادي استطاع
التاهل الى البريميرليج الموسم المقبل بعد
غيابه 32 عاما شهره الوافد الجديد تاتي من
ملعبه الفريد وهو يتواجد في مقاطعه صغيره
وتبلغ الساعه الجماهيريه فيه لعشره الاف
مشجع فقط الامر لم يتوقف هنا هذا الملعب
الصغير بعض مداخله تتواجد داخل ووسط
المنازل وبالتالي فان بعض المشجعين
سيدخلون الى الملعب عبر منازل خاصه
بسكانها وهي ظاهره سنشهدها لاول مره في
الكاميرا
[موسيقى]